[Música]
es un placer estar con ustedes Soy Paula
Jiménez Correa y les doy la bienvenida
Así es Asia el magacín quincenal de
France 24 que aborda las múltiples
realidades de este continente Estos son
nuestros titulares
Taiwán se abastece de armas ante la
amenaza y expansión militar de China
Estados Unidos el principal socio de La
Isla ha aprobado la venta por más de 619
millones de dólares que incluye misiles
y equipos de defensa
en China el gobierno de chillín se
mostró listo a mantener y reforzar las
relaciones con Brasil tras la firma de
varios acuerdos de cooperación bilateral
logrados durante la visita de Luis
Ignacio Lula da Silva a Beijing
India le acuesta al mijo como una de las
alternativas para combatir el hambre y
el cambio climático en el mundo les
contaremos como este autóctono cereal
podría ser clave para la solución a
problemas del futuro
iniciamos nuestro recorrido por el
continente asiático en Taiwán que
acelera el abastecimiento de armas ante
la amenaza militar de China la
presidenta Saint gweng ha prometido
seguir fortaleciendo sus fuerzas armadas
luego de que Beijing mantuviera durante
tres días constantes ejercicios
militares para poner a prueba las
capacidades en condiciones reales de
combate después de haber practicado
ataques de precisión y el bloqueo de La
Isla Estados Unidos principal socio de
Taiwán ha aprobado una millonaria venta
de armas de defensa para analizar y
conocer las capacidades militares tanto
de Taiwán como de China conectamos con
Jorge Malena director de la carrera de
posgrado sobre China de la Universidad
Católica Argentina señor Malena Muchas
gracias por aceptar esta invitación y
empiezo preguntándole Con qué armamento
cuenta Taiwán para enfrentar La amenaza
de Beijing
Hola Paula Muchas gracias por la
invitación Bueno básicamente Tenemos que
tener en cuenta que a la luz de que este
teatro de operaciones para un eventual
conflicto armado entre China y Taiwán
donde por supuesto los Estados Unidos va
a jugar un papel preeminente es
aeronaval a tales efectos la prioridad
en la construcción de unas fuerzas
armadas taiwanesas pasibles de enfrentar
un ataque chino guarda relación con la
posesión de una armada de una fuerza
aérea e incluso capacidad misilística
con base en tierra o en el propio mar
que haga posible hacer frente a esta
amenaza de china en ese contexto hemos
leído recientemente sobre el
otorgamiento la provisión por parte de
Estados Unidos a Taiwán de capacidades
misilísticas esto es un factor crucial
Porque no solo podrían ser utilizadas
para derribar a aviones del ejército
Popular de liberación chino sino también
hundir unidades navales de la armada del
ejército Popular de liberación chino y
hasta incluso eventualmente
incidir sobre objetivos terrestres en el
Continente chino Como por ejemplo
bases navales o aeropuertos militares
ahora háblenos de la capacidad militar
con la que cuenta china el conocido
gigante asiático
bueno China ya desde la misma década de
1990 independientemente de lo que es el
objetivo militar de la reunificación con
Taiwán ha construido lo que ellos llaman
una Marina de aguas azules es decir una
Marina oceánica que tenga la capacidad
de proyección de fuerzas previo a los
noventas por sobre todo en las primeras
tres décadas de existencia de la
República popular china su Armada era
básicamente para la defensa costera hoy
en día china cuenta con dos portaaviones
operativos un tercer portaavión que está
siendo puesto a pruebas para posterior Y
ser operativo un importante fuerza
aeronaval a sí mismo una fuerza aérea
estratégica de proyección a la distancia
y así también ya china cuenta con una
Infantería de Marina antes de hacerle la
tercera pregunta lo invito a usted señor
Malena y a nuestros televidentes a echar
un vistazo a este mapa en el que podemos
ver los 13 países que actualmente poseen
una embajada de Taiwán en sus
territorios y deseamos que siete de
ellos se encuentran en el continente
americano ante esto señor Malena hace
unas semanas la presidenta de Taiwán
Saint estuvo en Guatemala y Belice para
ratificar y reforzar Los lazos pero
también vimos que hace poco Honduras
rompió relaciones con taipei para
restablecer las con Beijing A qué se
debe que Taiwán esté perdiendo aliados
internacionales Por qué Buscar a China
en este momento
sí es una realidad que en materia
internacional gradualmente la llamada
República de china en Taiwán ha visto
notoriamente disminuido su espacio
internacional
a modo de ejemplo desde que asumió al
poder en el año 2016 el actual gobierno
liderado por saeing en el caso
específico de América Latina ha perdido
a Panamá en el año 2017 a El Salvador y
a la República Dominicana en el 2018 a
Nicaragua en el 2021 y más reciente este
año a Honduras esto implica que el total
de estados que reconocen
diplomáticamente a la llamada República
de china en Taiwán son solamente 13 uno
de ellos en Europa el Vaticano otro de
ellos en África la exoazilandia hoy es
suatini y cuatro en Oceanía y siete en
América del Sur América Central y el
Caribe agradecemos a Jorge Malena por su
análisis en otro tema un encuentro de
dos gigantes comerciales China y Brasil
fortalecieron sus relaciones comerciales
tras la reciente reunión del presidente
chillín con su homólogo brasileño Luis
Ignacio Lula da Silva en Beijing que
logró varios nuevos acuerdos en
diferentes Campos como el Tecnológico e
Industrial a continuación les explicamos
En qué consiste el acercamiento de China
a América Latina en el informe de Samuel
Salgado
se expande a toda marcha por América
Latina con intercambios comerciales
cercanos a los 500 mil millones de
dólares en 2022 según Beijing el país se
ha convertido en el segundo mayor socio
comercial de la región que
históricamente ha sido zona de
influencia de Estados Unidos y en países
como chile Perú y ya es el primer Aliado
comercial el reciente apretón de manos
entre el presidente brasileño Luis
Ignacio Lula da Silva y su homólogo
simboliza la cooperación entre dos
gigantes comerciales
estoy convencido de que un desarrollo
sostenido Sólido y constante de las
relaciones entre China y Brasil
desempeñará un papel positivo e
importante en la promoción de la paz la
estabilidad la prosperidad y el
desarrollo en la región y más allá la
visita china logró varios nuevos
acuerdos en industria comunicación y
tecnología y representa una garantía en
el suministro de materias primas
codiciadas por Beijing como el hierro
aluminio y estaño tenemos una relación
extraordinaria con china una relación
que madura y se fortalece cada día esta
Alianza comercial también marca el
resurgimiento de las brics el bloque de
las economías emergentes más importantes
del mundo y el protagonismo de china en
la globalización pero
Hasta qué punto la presencia comercial
influye en otros aspectos desde que
china se consolidó como la segunda
Economía del mundo Cada vez son menos
los países que reconocen la soberanía de
Taiwán pasamos a India porque de acuerdo
con estimaciones de las Naciones Unidas
A mediados de este año se convertirá en
el país más poblado del mundo las
proyecciones indican que tendrá 1428
millones de personas frente a los 1425
millones que tiene China no hace mucho
la previsión era que India no tendría
ese título hasta más avanzada la década
Pero la fecha se ha adelantado por una
caída en la tasa de natalidad en China
la ONU modificó las estimaciones ya que
había establecido que esto sucedería A
mediados de abril
seguimos en India porque el 2023 ha sido
establecido por la ONU como el año del
mijo para deleite de India donde este
grano es autóctono es uno de los
cereales más antiguos conocidos por la
civilización humana y ahora ocupa un
lugar central en la lucha contra el
cambio climático y el hambre mundial ya
que la guerra en Ucrania provocó una
escasez de trigo nuestros corresponsales
nos cuentan sobre las bondades de este
alimento
un grano antiguo perdido en el tiempo
los mijos ahora están luchando por un
asiento en la mesa
la chef pachinka batia conoció por
primera vez el grano en la cocina de su
abuela pero fue hace solo cuatro años
que comenzó a cocinar con mi hijo como
profesional
creo que el mijo es un mejor sustituto
en lugar de usar solo trigo porque te
mantiene lleno por más tiempo comes
menos y es energía de liberación lenta
mi hijo es ilimitada considerado un
alimento obsoleto la reputación del mijo
está cambiando en parte Gracias al
impulso de los agricultores indios a más
de 1000 kilómetros de distancia en el
estado de telagana nos encontramos con
el primero agricultor de mijo de India
vershetiradar
entonces actualmente este cultivo tiene
60 días y lo cosecharemos después de 100
días
durante un viaje de trabajo birre
descubrió este antiguo grano cultivado
por sus antepasados desde 2008 ha
viajado por todo el país capacitando y
convenciendo a más de 10.000
agricultores para que cambien al mijo
no es fácil convencer a los agricultores
de que cultiven un cultivo en lugar del
otro no nos escucharán la mayoría de los
agricultores solían cultivar caña de
azúcar que requiere más agua que el mijo
durante 12 meses
[Música]
birno es el único que Apuesta por el
mijo para los científicos este grano de
Diez mil años podría ser la semilla del
futuro en las afueras de hiderabat la
capital de telagana se encuentra el
extenso campus del instituto
internacional de investigación de
cultivos para trópicos semiáridos
[Música]
el doctor es el Custodio de estos
diminutos granos donde comienza la vida
Esto es mi hijo esto se almacenó en 1978
el banco contiene 79,000 variedades de
mijo considerado Smart Food según el
Instituto
naturalmente Estos son resistentes al
clima por ejemplo el mijo Perla es un
cultivo que crece en las condiciones más
duras y Si vemos que se está produciendo
un cambio climático probablemente estos
sean los cultivos que se verán menos
afectados que muchos otros cultivos una
de las funciones de los investigadores
aquí es proporcionar a los agricultores
marginados desde Asia hasta África
conocimientos técnicos sobre el cultivo
de mijo India convenció a la ONU para
que declarara 2023 como el año
Internacional del mijo el país ya es el
principal productor de mi hijo del mundo
con 15 millones de toneladas por año si
bien la guerra en Ucrania ha
interrumpido el comercio mundial de
trigo India espera llenar el pasillo de
cereales con este grano maravilloso
[Música]
y para el cierre les dejo el siguiente
dato en Corea del Norte cuentan el año
en el que viven a partir de 1912 cuando
nació Kim ilzuno fundador de la
República popular democrática de Corea
el nombre oficial del país a esto se le
llama el calendario juche por lo que
para sus ciudadanos Este 2023 es el año
llegamos al final de esta edición de Así
es Asia Muchas gracias por acompañarnos
y los invito a enviar sus comentarios a
la cuenta de Twitter que aparece en sus
pantallas y a seguir toda la información
en nuestra página web Franz 24.com Hasta
pronto